so some news from 1984 uh first the
surgeon general
said that they're going to start putting
you know you know certain general
warnings
and if you see them on cigarette
boxes of cigarettes usually it's
associated with
things that you eat and uh you know
things that could cause
physical harm to you uh but now they're
gonna start putting certain general
warnings
on speech so staying on this theme of
speech causing
physical harm or some sort of harm
speech being violent
that's the plan now and here is the
surgeon general
explaining today i
issued a surgeon general's advisory
on the dangers of health misinformation
surgeon general advisories are reserved
for urgent public health threats
and while those threats have often been
related to what we eat
drink and smoke today we live in a world
where misinformation poses an imminent
and insidious threat to our nation's
health
health misinformation is false
inaccurate or misleading information
about health
according to the best evidence at the
time and while it often appears
innocuous
on social media apps on retail sites or
search engines
the truth is that misinformation takes
away our freedom
to make informed decisions about our
health and the health of our loved ones
during the covet 19 pandemic health
misinformation has led people
to resist wearing masks in high risk
settings
it's led them to turn down proven
treatments and to choose not to get
vaccinated
this has led to avoidable illnesses in
depth
simply put health information has cost
us
lives misinformation
takes away our freedom
if that's not an orwellian statement i
mean that is that is
i'd have to read the book again it
sounds like something that would
actually be in the book itself
so misinformation takes away our freedom
in other words you know
a statement that
you don't like takes away your freedom
free so that's free speech free speech
takes away our freedom free speech
undermines our freedom
is what's being claimed here i thought
it was really fascinating that he
uh specifically mentions this is the the
surgeon general
saying that uh well misinformation about
masks
made people reluctant to wear masks
okay well yeah do you know who
at the beginning of the beginning of the
pandemic was telling people not to wear
masks
the surgeon general sent out a tweet
the surgeon general's office not the
same guy but certain general's office
sent out a tweet back in whatever was
march
of last year saying stop wearing masks
in all caps
public health officials dr fauci said
don't wear a mask
now they say wear the mask but the point
is
and i think they were right the first
time by the way but the point is
that when on this
on this basis here when the surgeon
general had said
a year ago don't wear the mask if you
said no i think you should wear a mask
you would have been that would have been
tagged as
misinformation and now they say wear the
mask and you say no you know what i
think you were right the first time
now that's misinformation
opposing views both are misinformation
because
what is misinformation it's not we don't
label things or they're not labeling
things misinformation
based on its relation to truth
it's misinformation based on its
relation to the claims that they are
making
and that is the very obvious problem
with the government's
campaign against misinformation it's the
problem with labeling misinformation
some sort of public health
threats many problems with it
once again equating speech with violence
which is a direct attack on the very
concept of free speech
but the other issue is that what do they
consider misinformation
they have made themselves the scientific
authority
and to trust the science is to trust
them
conflating the two it's exactly the same
if you don't trust them then you don't
trust the science
yeah the thing about vaccines
um sure there could be misinformation
claims that are made about vaccines on
either
side of the debate that are simply wrong
sure that exists
but much of what is labeled vaccine
misinformation
is really a matter of priority right
it's it's someone expressing their
priority
the risk level that they're comfortable
with
many of the people who have not gotten
the vaccine
it's because if you listen to what
they're saying
okay just most of the average people
haven't got it
you actually listen to what they're
saying what they're saying is
um you know i
i'm worried about potential side effects
i'm worried about we don't know about
the long term
and i'm i'm judging this base and then
i'm also comparing that to
the threat posed to me uh in my own
demographic
group by kovid and i'm i'm making a
judgment
and that's why i don't want to get the
vaccine
now you could disagree with that
decision you could say that you think
it's a foolish decision or whatever
that's that's your own personal uh
opinion based on your own priorities
but that's what we're talking about so
how can that be misinformation
it's just someone weighing risks
balancing everything out and saying you
know
here's here's how here's how it all
shakes out for me personally
here's the risk level that i'm
comfortable with
here are the risks that i'm risks that
i'm worried about and then these risks
over here i'm not as worried about
that's i don't how can that even be
misinformation it's it's it is a matter
of personal
priority that's it
um meanwhile gen saki kind of on the
same theme here
dropped this bomb rather casually let's
listen
this is a big issue of misinformation
specifically on the pandemic
in terms of actions alex that we have
taken or we're working to take i should
say
from the federal government we've
increased disinformation research and
tracking
within the surgeon general's office
we're flagging problematic posts for
facebook that spread this information
we're working with doctors and medical
professionals to connect
uh two connected medical experts with
popular with popular who are popular
with their audiences with
uh with accurate information and boost
trusted content so we're helping
get trusted content out there that's
nice of them
they're flagging misinformation for
facebook
really really helpful they're trying to
help out
uh so this is something to keep in mind
and i like how she she mentions that
like it's no big deal um
nothing controversial about it oh yeah
we're doing this with facebook
we're we are telling as a
you know as the white house as a
political entity
we're telling facebook what qualifies as
misinformation or disinformation
and she says that like it's no big deal
like it's it's obvious that they would
be doing that
and actually it is kind of obvious that
they would be doing that that doesn't
make it okay though
but it's something to keep in mind when
you hear about
um how facebook is nothing but a private
company
that's all no different from the uh
from the small town baker and so if you
think that the small town baker should
be able to
bake whatever cake he wants then
facebook
should be able to do whatever they want
of course the absurdity of that argument
is that the people who make it
don't think the baker should be able to
bake whatever cake he wants
they think that the decisions made by a
baker
in colorado are
more significant and um carry with them
a deeper
national and global consequence than the
decisions made by
these multi-billion dollar corporations
that control the way that people
communicate
and the ideas that are allowed to be
communicated
that that's that's the the utter
absurdity of it
the same people who make that comparison
oh you're the one who said
they bake whatever the cake they want
yeah no you see
the conflict here the irrationality it's
on your end
because it's very easy for me to explain
how facebook is different from a baker
it literally it harms no one if a baker
just bakes whatever cake he wants
um doesn't want to bake a gay wedding
cake
or or he'll say you like sell you a cake
but he's not gonna cut that's
that's really what the issue was right
it's not even we're refusing service to
gay couples it's just
we're not gonna make a customized cake
for this particular event
you can still buy a cake from us and
customize it yourself or you can go to
any of the dozens of other bakeries
around
and get the cake that you want now in
that scenario
it harms no one
there is no national consequence
whatsoever
what happens when these multi-billion
dollar big tech companies
that control the way that billions of
people communicate
what happens when they have political
bias ideological bias
[Music]
i would say the consequences are quite a
bit more severe listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated